[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want and we got geo
okay today we have not been in
jk universe in like forever your channel
plug your channel what's your channel
uh so you can visit me at geo antoinette
you can visit me
uh in vegas you can visit me at barbell
brigade uh you can visit me at barbell
brigade.com we have apparel we have
supplements
uh you can visit me here jk news you can
visit me on his channel
what is it georgia tsukala you can visit
me on their podcast
you can visit me on our podcast yeah you
can visit me at your gym
yep yes okay editor you can pair that
down a little bit
speaking of new channel you [ __ ] got
one i just saw that [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you didn't tell
anybody about anybody anything thinking
about starting new or not thinking i'm
starting a new channel sit yeah
i want to do a food channel hey i'm
still finally fine
i'm still tinkering away at the concept
here but it's basically
uh storytelling through food and i want
to tell the history of food
and like in a very like cinematic way
sandwiches first
all different cultures honestly you're
told you're totally right sandwiches
hurt
sandwiches start taking a [ __ ] on
sandwiches yeah talk
[ __ ] [ __ ] sandwiches so in a previous
video uh not joe uh casey was talking
about how he
hates any sandwich all sandwiches [ __ ]
up yeah
it's funny that you're gonna be starting
with that are you really starting with
that
yeah yeah so i'm picturing when you say
cinematic i'm picturing like
lots of voice overs and not so much like
a
a cast or like a guest guest personality
driven it's not like that
it's it's visually driven like it's just
close-up shot macro shots of food being
prepared
cooked asmr and adr yeah it's all
it's all sound and visuals like chef's
table but even more yeah even more so
yeah yeah
and then a lot of like animation stuff
to narrate like the history of how
things
came to be or whatever so that's kind of
like what i'm i'm working with right now
and the first story is a sandwich
sandwich what kind of sandwich how the
sandwich came to be the just the concept
of a sandwich
the idea of a sandwich how it came i
don't know the history behind that i
gotta watch your video yeah i actually
picked it because i thought it was the
most well-known one
sandwiches yeah i learned about it in
school and like i don't know for some
reason i figured like because i learned
it in school like a lot of other people
knew knew about the history of the sam
no i have no
[Laughter]
at this [ __ ] in school how are you down
oh well yeah this morning
right now and i was like man i wish i
was sitting in josie dude i want to take
a look
what's going on i do remember that like
in sixth grade specifically
i made the mistake of wearing silk
boxers and i just heard
you had some boxers well we stole them
we stole them because it was fun
it was that ross you stole silk boxers
you know when you're like in the steely
yeah you steal everything
it's like whatever you know you're just
like at ross
and you're like go grab a couple of
these
let me get this grab a couple of those
and you're just grabbing things and then
i'm like i decide to wear them and then
you're just sitting there and then you
just constantly and it's like your
underwear kid is that sensitive
if it's silk it's like in high school i
mean it's like foreplay
freaking sensitive you feel the silk in
high school a gust of wind and you're
like all right well
i got to stay here touching your thighs
yeah dude it's just like whoa touching
your thigh
grabbing chalk you're like oh my god oh
my god like that looks like my dick it's
the same size
yeah yeah yeah it's actually that's
actually a little thick she's just going
like this and you're like all the guys
i came
are you [ __ ] kidding me
that's what guys have to go through yeah
girls don't even know
dude is it that's probably why we had
kids so damn young and died so damn
early you guys are
stupid we're dumb we're dumb dude we're
dumber than you even think
yeah girls give us way too much credit
way too much
yeah we're really intelligent i'll get
asked the question i'm like wow she
thinks i know the answer there
she has no idea i just sometimes like
yeah i'm like i can't believe she thinks
i'm listening
there are times where he he looks real
pensive and he looks like he's just like
in deep
like like yeah like he's just really
concentrating and i'm like what are you
thinking about and he's like
nothing at all absolutely nothing i'm
like really like there's no visual i'm
thinking about like
should i go with the 17-inch wheels
literally nothing's going on well you'll
be telling me something about like a
revelation you had
like i just talked to my mom my real
life you [ __ ] dare finish that
sentence what
that you don't listen to me when i'm
going through [ __ ] i am listening
but i'm trying to draw the parallels
between that and 17-inch wheels
and if not yeah that's like when i
bought i figured
you know so nothing sounds better than
saying 17-inch wheels but he literally
listened to you he was recounting
what you no i appreciate that i was i
just didn't want our marriage to end
on this video so i was trying to stop
him and be like during a breakthrough
he needs to be listening okay what'd you
say
like nikki was trying to tell me about a
dream she had this morning and i was
like that's great baby i gotta go
[Laughter]
sounds great no idea what's the dream i
feel like that happens to you every day
yeah i always find out what her dream
was last night whether i like it or not
oh my god
does she have a lot of recurring dreams
uh no she just has different dreams and
um yeah i'm just not that into dream
stories i'm just not
i'm just not very into it did you ever
have a dream you don't drink money no
not really i don't know
either or at least i don't remember damn
y'all have no dreams that
sucks you remember your dreams vividly i
got
goals i live it i have everyday hustle
i have crazy ass dreams and they're
really vivid almost every day
but like you i don't really give a [ __ ]
about dream stories because it's not
real life
so i don't even want to talk about mine
but it explains like where you're at
like
explain [ __ ] it just explains [ __ ]
rem sleepin
don't explain anything explain to me
being an elephant trainer
and teaching them how to play soccer uh
that one is that you need more patience
like you're too quick to jump to
negative [ __ ] and you just have to take
it slow
that's what if that's the kind of dreams
that she's having i'd be pretty
interested
elephants playing soccer i was l i was
an elephant
coach for a elephant soccer team because
you weren't the elephants
did they have uniforms that would have
been tight where's the number on the
chest or on the back
it's on the back on the forehead oh it's
painted on them i don't know sweatpants
imagine they have sweat bands
the numbers were on the foreheads it
would be great but i gave a motivational
speech on winning
sweat bands on there what did it sound
like i was just like man we gotta
[ __ ] win dude what's up
this is a great coach that's a good card
yo
in what's up forgot what they showed up
for they wanted to win
we had a group huddle what sport were
they playing soccer
oh socks and soccer are they
uh on two feet or on four they're all
four they're [ __ ] using their
important
their nose their [ __ ] yeah so then
they they would kick from the back
and then another one will catch you with
the nose and [ __ ] and [ __ ] and i'm
like hell yeah i think it's the goal
post they're huge man they're [ __ ]
massive
they better be so the goalie can just
lay there yeah he just sits and
blocks the entire thing it's blowing
cheating
going and then it rolls the ball over or
they have to strike it well i guess they
could catch it so it's a different type
of soccer but that's hands you can't do
hands yeah but the trunk is a hand and
he says they could use it i didn't know
that was that's [ __ ] up i don't think
goldie's only goalies
you see they're they're [ __ ] trunks
but they also ride
they also use their hand to walk with oh
you mean their
nose okay i remember learning how to
play soccer the first time i think it
was
in second or third grade and then you
know when you're a kid if you learn one
rule
that's like the cardinal rule yeah so
when we learned
no hands and then you would just like
when people kick the ball
[ __ ] hard and even though it's coming
straight at their face
instead of going like this kids are just
no hats
and all the kids are just getting
[ __ ] whaled on because everyone's
just trying to be honorable
no hands douche cuz i remember i
remember the same thing if you were
playing soccer growing up and you
touched it with your hands it's a big
no-no
you're [ __ ] excommunicated bro you
could never show your face you might as
today's video is brought to you by human
which is health
via modern nutrition and it's pretty
cool because they have so many
keto friendly products and you know
keto has been getting some pretty good
traction right a lot of people are
talking about it it's
it's helped a lot of my friends and me
myself included
and so i'm super excited working with
human because they sent me
over a bunch of awesome treats and
things that actually work
within my diet and i can enjoy it it
tastes good
and going through this journey of me
learning about
keto and like how you know a lot of us
are just damaging our bodies with the
junk
that's available to us and they're cheap
and it tastes great
one thing that stuck out to me is the
average american consumes about
17 teaspoons of sugar oh damn
a day that's a lot dude that's a lot
if you guys have sugar get 17 teaspoons
and look at how much that is
and you just never know what's in these
products right like
sometimes i just want to get like a
granola bar or something because i want
a snack
but you look and it's got how many grams
of sugar this stuff has sugar this stuff
has sugar and i'm like what even
even fruit juices which i thought was
healthy that [ __ ] is loaded with sugar
extra sugar yeah and from that point on
i was like no wonder
i can't lose weight and no wonder you
know i'm always hungry and all this
stuff because i found out that sugar
also makes you super hungry all the time
yeah and what's dope about a human is
that
they also use real organic ingredients
so if
you're trying to clean up your diet and
you don't want to eat stuff that is
super processed or has a ton of
preservatives they have really healthy
options whether you're on keto or not
for me
i'm not on keto but i am very conscious
of the amount of sugar that i take in
per day so that's why there's snacks
like their keto food bars help you out
because you can track the macros you can
figure out
oh cool i have too much sugar i ate too
much sugar today i'm gonna reduce some
of the sugar later on in the day
and that's what they're about they're a
nutrition company that wants to take the
mystery
out of macros and if you want to try
this out you get 10 percent off
go to human.com that's hvmn.com
off the record hvmn.com
authorized to get 10 off your first
order
thank you guys thank you my best soccer
memory is i was i had the ball
finally i was only goalie right i was
only ever a goalie
but this one time they had me play right
wing or whatever the [ __ ] it was
and um i got the ball finally and i
start charging towards the goal and i'm
hearing everyone going whoa
wait steve's oh no and then sure enough
i was running towards my own goal with
the [ __ ] ball yeah thankfully i
didn't kick a goal but
you should have just say [ __ ] you i knew
the whole time so that's what you should
do oh yeah i was like i'm winding up
guys
i'm gonna take the long way
it is confusing it is confusing i feel
like steve was like that in every sport
team that he was in
going to the wrong goal he's like it's
[ __ ] my turn and then he's like
he was the one that was picked last and
then the leaders were always like no
[ __ ] you get him no i don't want him you
get him i was the one
and i always got this [ __ ] job like
goalie where basically they're just like
you got long lives man
well no i got goalie because they didn't
want me on the field like with the ball
i mean so they're just like hey dude
just like you know if it gets near steve
just like everyone start scrambling dude
just
start diving and [ __ ] and then when i
was playing baseball i got catcher and i
got like left field
so that means you suck really yeah
catcher in little league is like
the coach is underhand pitching people
so there's no point in having a [ __ ]
catcher even is this a true story yeah
it's all true yeah
i was not very good at any sport when
you were younger were you always like
one of the taller kids growing up i was
always the tallest kid in my class
my whole school even oh [ __ ] yeah but it
didn't do so that's why they always
picked you for the sports
and you didn't want to go well i would
get in i would get into the sports
because my parents put me in the sports
but then i just never worked out
ever he's like can't you see that your
son is a writer
and a clown basketball i got recruited
basically by the
the coach because so i could be rebound
guy but i suck at basketball too
but i got most improved because i suck
so bad that's
actually what happens most improved it's
a shitty one exactly no it's not it's
underrated i think
most improvement is underrated yeah i
don't know they should have that for the
nba
yeah they actually do have the most
improved yeah
i was just reading something about some
some guy got most improved yeah i don't
know
i think it's comeback i think it's
comeback player though isn't it i don't
know maybe i'm wrong
i don't know nba i always felt like most
improved was a [ __ ] embarrassment
it is it is i got that academically a
lot you feel embarrassed
no i was actually proud i'm like i got
straight c's now okay interface
but they're better now yeah that's
what's important right
even though we could focus on that they
suck but what's more important is they
got better look at the personal trainer
coming out no i'm not i like that
you're not a personal trainer no what
yeah yeah i am i
am yeah i forgot i was a coach yeah yeah
so
i feel like i was like a 60 year old
grandma doing squats like it's not where
you're at right now it's where you came
from but yeah and then she turned into
barcode thank you honey
and she's all swole now you know yeah
big old little
muscular tits right you touch your
grandma's like that yeah all the time
is that okay is that okay to say you're
touching their pecs only yeah i'm just
like i just want to make sure they're
contracting
yeah and with bart i'm just like yeah
this is good this is very good there's
some personal trainer at his old gym
that looks like he only has old lady
clients that he feels up
and they like it how old are the old
guys is he a sexy man is he a sexy dying
piece
nah he's a [ __ ] scam artist dude he's
the guy that we work with and he's a
[ __ ] clown this guy
does he have a bluetooth on the entire
time low-key he might as well be he
might as well
look like one of those guys might as
well have he looks like in his in his
early years he was probably one of the
like pretty boys
and now he's like a 50 year old pretty
boy huh yeah
he'll stretch ladies out on the table
and literally be halfway inside of him
bro yeah and they kind of
he has both of their ankles down like
that and stretching them out and he'll
he'll he'll make [ __ ] up
like he'll make [ __ ] up like we need to
stretch my legs every day
every day one time i heard him talk to a
client and he was saying like oh the
reason why your legs are so sore
is because your it bands are so tight
that the blood flow
is dripping so by the time it drips down
your calf that's why your calf is so
tight
that's gonna push your knees apart and
put my my hip he's like he's like yeah
the vastus lateralis on on this side is
congruent to the uh sarcomeres on this
side so that's why you feel that way so
they gotta put this ball gag in
yeah and you gotta come in the back room
with me and hang out for a little bit
but i feel like all the old ladies
get that extra attention from him too so
that's why
they're his clients and and for the sake
of like you know when they're working
out with them
they damage their spines they [ __ ]
themselves up because
[ __ ] he injures people so just watch out
for people like that
he [ __ ] them up he has them doing
[ __ ] dude and it's crazy it's fun to
watch but it's also like
why would they let him be there because
he's thrusting in him yeah
he pays rent like everyone else people
need friends i think
that's the other thing though too they
just want to hang out with the guy yeah
certificates to become a traders
easy dude you can but it's also like
what jio said some of them are
very easy to get some people have like a
four-year degree like this guy
and then gets but even but even then
even if it doesn't really
there's some people that do like they
have like one day eight-hour courses to
become so like
the certifications matter too and a lot
of people on instagram
they look really good and then they
they're they're like you want to [ __ ]
follow my regimen
take steroids
those are the best ones yeah there's
this guy
that i get on my youtube ads and he's
talking about how he's like you know if
you want to lose weight you know most
people have a bunch of toxic poop in
their body i've seen the toxic poop guy
yeah that wish he would shut the [ __ ] up
he's just selling a supplement saying
that like if you get rid of this toxic
poop
you know then you're gonna start losing
weight is it like some probiotic [ __ ]
nah it's a [ __ ] it's a it's a juice
cleanse pretty much
it's a laxative you're gonna [ __ ] your
brains out and then be like oh look i
weigh lighter now like oh it's great
yeah when you're dehydrated and you [ __ ]
everything else
out of course you're going to lose some
pounds dude i'm like i know why i got
toxic poop powder
i don't need your [ __ ] lecture food
toxic poop then you break
that's crazy i don't want to hear your
[ __ ] about toxic poop yeah they just
make stuff up they just make up
make up fake problems and they're like
all right well you buy my supplement now
and then people
watch it and they're like oh yeah i have
that fake problem too like [ __ ] that's
the reason why
i think there's a fake problem why do we
believe the fake problem because it's
easier to believe that then you're
eating
more than you need to you know that's
what even like viagra was
like they're trying to research
something else i think for depression or
something
and then it wasn't getting a bonus then
they failed and i was like oh wait but
it gives you a boners
yeah so let's let's let's yeah rebrand
it and remarket it
really it was like a heart medication
right yeah a lot of these drugs oh my
god imagine that yeah they're just
creating something and then they're like
but there are these side effects let's
just rebrand it and market it this way
we're trying to cure cancer
okay this makes boners let's just study
the bone that's really interesting
let's do all the bone stuff let's make
this a whole business and then cancer
people like oh no when they when are we
gonna get it
oh yeah that's isn't that how they
develop ecstasy because it was supposed
to be
for uh depression or schizophrenia or
one of the yeah
right dude sounds about right and then i
mean [ __ ] it does cure
depression in a lot of ways short term
short term yeah i don't know
yeah same thing with a lot of the
antidepressants too i think they were
just i don't even know what they're
researching but then it came out that it
made you feel a little bit good so
they're like we gotta create another
problem so that this solves the problem
they just create a whole giant marketing
campaign that's too real can we go back
to the toxic
[ __ ] to the to the old guy that's
molesting grandmas
that guy's cool but he he probably has
viagra on him at all times because he's
one of those guys too he'll like hit on
my clients
like back does he have like a nice
lineup kind of yeah he's
bro one time he came into the gym like
drunk and he was uh
he was just drunk and he started just
talking [ __ ] to me he came up to me it
was like
he was like you know what he goes hey
you should why'd you stop fighting man
you gotta start
start fighting again and i was like no
i'm good bro and he goes nah man you
could have been the welterweight champ
of the world like i swear to god he said
this to me and i'm like i think he's
talking [ __ ] i think he's your fan yeah
he's complimenting him
it comes back around he goes he goes why
don't you fight me then and i was like
yeah that was awesome
i was like and i was like and that's
what it led to and i was like nah man
i'm trying to i'm trying to do these
pull-ups right now
and he's talking to me and he's like
kind of shit-faced and he smells like
alcohol he smells like alcohol i guess
he came from a funeral
but he's known to kind of hit the sauce
a lot so he's just you know he's a real
cool guy
hit him up his name is cameron i'll give
you guys look at the bottom right here
he's a great trainer you know like he
tried bro he was like yo like let's just
go right here
let's fight right now and i was like no
i'm not gonna fight you bro get the [ __ ]
out of here
and he goes on this tie right he's like
i knew you were a [ __ ] bra i knew your
[ __ ]
and then he and then he was like i got
30 suits i got 30 suits on my house
people think i'm a personal trainer but
actually
i got 30 suits i'm a real estate agent
bro like this is what i do on the side
and he just he's crazy he's absolutely
crazy i just don't think you need 30
suits
i got like two especially for guys you
guys don't have much color
one a day for a whole month max maybe
seven yeah well maybe
if you want to if you want to wolf of
wall street doesn't even have [ __ ] 30
suits bro you know what i mean this guy
is full of [ __ ]
30 suits and how how much you spent on
each suit like
hundred bucks or something like what the
[ __ ] is it how much is a suit in general
how about you spend like like half of
the 30 suit money on like a couple good
suits
some like really nice well he's a
trainer does he need suits oh he's a
real estate
and he also told me he goes yeah like i
also i work at i'm a manager i read
lobster too
and he was like i swear to god like bro
he was saying stuff to me where i was
like this is out of a [ __ ] movie
i've never been to a red lobster before
that's balling
biscuits dude really that's that's why
you don't understand why he needs suits
yeah
oh because he's a manager and lobster
nice but he's also a real estate guy
okay if you're working the floor you got
to be in a three-piece suit so there's a
lot of sketchy people that just
start doing fitness you know because a
lot of times you can you can get a lot
of clients from just kind of
just being a likable guy kind of
bullshitting and then looking semi-fit
yeah it looks semi-fit and then you just
get people
they'll be like oh can you train me and
that's that's the sad part where like i
guess
a good trainer is probably gonna [ __ ]
wreck your ass
but then but you're gonna get results
but the problem is people don't wanna
get their ass wrecked
they actually just wanna someone to talk
to and vent and feel like they sweat a
little bit i like that and then
but you end up but then you end up with
guys like this who was also a real
estate agent and manager at red lobster
versus someone that's dedicating their
life to wrecking people's asses but dude
there was this guy i used to
i used to go to la fitness where there
was this guy and he had to be like five
foot one
he's like the most grand stefan looking
[ __ ] i've ever
he always wore this puffy jacket or
whatever and he was a personal trainer
and they would be like
and he but he was always waiting for
somebody like it was he never had a
client he was always just like waiting
for a client
that never really i never saw the
question just patrolling
where all the cars were parked yeah it's
almost like he had a whistle in his
hands just waiting just twiddling around
with it just like you know what
someday i'll get a client in here but it
was like that it was like you'll never
bro
it's not you should have trained with
him and just see what the hype was i
know maybe he'd wreck my eyes there was
no hype he had no one
he had a whistle though that hasn't come
for something he has a whistle
he had a whistle that's how you know
he's legit yeah
he's a drill sergeant bro did he ever
use the whistle
i never saw i never saw him use it never
talk to anybody even
maybe it was a rape whistle yeah exactly
that makes sense yeah it's 5-1 you know
i mean like
[Music]
foreign